the once green hills of marmaris have
turned into this hectares of scorched
land
and smoke everywhere as firefighting
helicopters
douse the flames the fires here are
mostly contained now but
the damage they left behind is immense
in antalya's manav gut district this
farmer found a newly born baby goat
he's named it miracle
i'm only worried about these animals if
i'd died it wouldn't matter
when our village was being evacuated i
couldn't leave i asked my parents
if we die here shall we die together
with these animals and they said yes
so we stayed i wish those animals
survived and i was dead
instead they are innocent
volunteers have joined the firefighters
working across the southern region
like college student rayhan in antalya's
executive district
all seniors in our village survive the
fire except for my 82 year old
grandfather
he got poisoned by the smoke while
trying to put out the fire
i don't want other seniors to die
tourists had to be moved from some of
the hotels in mula's popular district of
bodrum as the fire spread down the hill
towards the seashore
the government suspects arson but
experts believe
excessive heat and strong winds are
likely to cause
climate change is also a crucial factor
turkey saw devastating floods in its
northern black sea region earlier in
july
for many years the mediterranean has
never seen such dry weather as it has in
the last 20 days
meteorologists have actually warned
fires are unavoidable in the next 15
days and may continue until september
the fire which started in marmaris has
now spread to other locations
the government has been criticized for a
shortage of firefighting aircraft
azerbaijan iran russia and ukraine have
sent equipment and personnel
but turkey's forestry minister warns the
humidity level is going
down in the coming days which means more
attention
and measures are needed to put out the
fires in turkey's southern green hills
and ease the pain of those who have lost
everything
cinnamon solo al jazeera istanbul